تتفاقم معاناه النازحين السوريين في
المخيمات بسبب انخفاض درجات الحراره
والاجواء الشتويه والمطره التي تسود
المنطقه درجات الحراره المنخفضه تدفع
النازحين الى استخدام ادوات بدائيه
للتدفئه ومثل الادوات البلاستيكيه
المستعمله و ما يستطيع النازحون جمعه من
الاراضي والبساتين المجاوره لكن استخدام
المواد البلاستيكيه للتدفئه يترك اثارا
اره جدا على صحه النازحين وخاصه على
النساء والاطفال كما اخبرنا النازحون في
هذا المخيم الذي نزح سكانه قبل اكثر من
خمسه اعوام من منطقه ريف حلب
الجنوبي تعيش اكثر من 80 عائله ظروفا صعبه
في ظل هذا الشتاء ودرجات الحراره المنخفضه
ف المخيم لا تصله ايه خدمات وهو بحاجه
الى عوا ز للخيم وايضا الى فرش ارضه
بما يبعد عن النازحين اثار الاوحال وغرق
الخيام بالمياه عندما تزداد كميات الهطل
المطري بحسب منسقو الاستجابه السوريه فان
اكثر من 2000 شخص فقدوا الماوى بسبب غرق
خيامهم خلال المنخفض الجوي الذي حل في
المنطقه
الفتره الماضيه كما ان الدفاع المدني
السوري قال بان اكثر من 17 حريقا نشب في
خيام النازحين بسبب الطهي داخل الخيام
واستخدام مواد بدائيه للتدفئه وعدم تزويد
الخيام بعوازل مناسبه تقي النازحين درجات
الحراره المنخفضه صهيب الخلف الجزيره ريف
ادلب